we have the latest numbers from last
week's new unemployment claims 3.8
million more people additional people
have lost their jobs we've been tracking
this weekly since the start of Corona of
I mean we always track it weekly but
we've been looking at numbers this bad
since the start of the virus some weeks
the numbers have been as high as 6.8
million in one week losing their jobs
this is now a reduction in new claims
3.8 million more people lost their jobs
last week so in total this is the
terrible news 30 million people have now
lost their jobs due to coronavirus to
give you a little context for that
number before this started the workforce
was believed to be a hundred and fifty
eight million in the United States 1 5 8
million 30 million is about 19 percent
19 percent of all working people have
lost their jobs in the United States in
the last six or seven weeks
this is nightmarish these are numbers
that are so outrageous that eight weeks
ago there would have been unimaginable
numbers the slightly okay news if we're
looking for trends right like if we
really if we want to find something the
slightly okay news is it's not six
million every week it's been diminishing
we had 6 point 6 million people lost
their job will yet six point eight then
six point six five point two then four
point four and now three point eight so
hopefully over the next four to six
weeks we'll see the numbers of new
claims continue to diminish eventually
hopefully we will see a net decrease in
the number of people who are not working
but this is not going to be quick you
know Trump talks about this v-shaped
recovery that'll be as quick or even
quicker than the decline doesn't seem
like it's going to be that way many jobs
that are being lost or permanent job
losses many businesses are not going to
reopen and what's also becoming
completely clear is that there hasn't
been enough stimulus from the government
we're now well into month number two of
this some states or about I mean here in
Massachusetts we're very close to
entering month number three and there
are still people who have not gotten
their $1200 checks
and even when they get the 1200 it's not
going to be enough this is going to be a
big deal remember that before this half
the country couldn't even afford an
unexpected $400 expense that was before
this those numbers are going to go way
way up they're gonna get much more ugly
as this continues we are going to need
more stimulus I would like to also see
infrastructure done and I'll talk next
week about how much more stimulus we are
likely to need as well as what an
infrastructure deal would look like and
you know the thing about Trump is
everything is always a crony capitalist
hit job even when as I said earlier
Trump is using a lot of the right tools
here to deal with this recession which
could become a depression or maybe
already is but it's not yet reflected in
all of the numbers Trump is often using
the right tools but it's always done in
the wrong way it's always that in a
corrupt way eliminating oversight for
the stimulus money the PPP program which
saw huge swaths of the funding go
directly to big businesses and
organizations that don't really need it
even organizations with large endowments
and a lot of small businesses getting
zero getting absolutely zero so next
week we'll talk about what would
infrastructure look like how much more
stimulus are we likely to need depending
on how this goes and related topics my
question to you you can get back to me
on Twitter at D Pakman is where do you
think unemployment will top out there
are people saying 40 million we're at 30
million now some people say 40 million
others are saying it's gonna be a full
50 55 million like a third of the
workforce if this extends for another
six to eight weeks to this degree let me
know where you see that tragic number
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman we've got a
tremendously good program for you today
check this out the first 500 people who
see this video and go to david
pakman.com slash skill will get a
premium membership to Skillshare for two
months completely free skill shares the
online learning community with thousands
of classes on almost anything you can
imagine always taught by experts they
have classes on drawing painting
photography video editing web design
running a small business and much more I
recently took a very interesting class
called simple productivity how to
accomplish more with less and got a
bunch of great personal productivity
tips out of it we should allow ourselves
a little time every week to either get
creative keep your brain sharp learn
something new it's great for mental
health and almost all the classes are
under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with skill share you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two whole months giving
you access to every class Skillshare
offers check it out I put the link right
underneath this video